here we go just that angle just a little
yeah like that better
there we are
color refreshed I decided to give the
pink a rest for a bit
I needed something I think a little less
cotton candy for a little bit so
slightly more subdued something that
maybe you need to do a double take your
first thing uh-huh so yeah that's the
new collar also went a little bit closer
on the backs and the size and had them
do a fade with it um so it's going from
significantly shorter than it was up to
about where it was before so adjusted
that a little bit to look like a mermaid
well yeah it was kind of kind of the
angle I was going with Carey Mulligan
and Andrew Garfield have Oscar
nominations they both appeared on Doctor
Who prior to their bid big breaks
Rebecca I will be curious to see how
many Oscar facts you can tie into Doctor
Who we'll see what you've got
ah okay variety is the spice of life
chaos is the barbecue sauce of life your
hair is the chocolate of life ooh
I don't know what I said I hope that was
a compliment well I took it as one now
I'm hungry but that's okay
I have strawberries
so yeah let's let's talk about the Oscar
nominations now as has happened the last
few years I've seen very few of the
films that have received a lot of
nominations and actually the movie that
I saw every recently that I was that I
thought was gonna pick up a lot
basically anything that I thought should
have been nominated wasn't like my big
plan was to root for Taron Egerton to
pick up Best Actor for raka man it
wasn't even nominated um I was really
gonna pull for knives out in anything
they wanted to nominate it in barely a
dang thing so yeah my feelings of this
arguments are on Joker flaring up again
getting bad-tempered yeah what look I
I'll get to Joker stick a pin in that
one I'll get to it I just I didn't want
to lead with it okay um but broadly
speaking like I've seen very little of
what's been nominated which is there's
that's pretty much standard for me and
the Oscars at this point I and honestly
I think that's standard for anybody who
doesn't have an art house theater local
to them and who doesn't like go way out
of their way to frequent it because
unless you do you haven't seen most of
these movies either you haven't had the
opportunity to see a lot of them so
often ones that are nominated the ones
that I actually plan to see at some
point I do want to see Jo Jo rabbit I
want to see Little Women I definitely
want to see parasite the Irishman is
kind of a back burner like maybe 1917
I'm curious to see how well the gimmick
holds up and I've been told to watch
once upon a time in Hollywood by people
who I trust enough that yeah I'll give
it a shot but I was
to let that one wait so I this is one of
those days where I'm probably gonna miss
a fair amount of the questions watch
parasite first I'll try like I don't
know time people time is not a thing I
have a lot of but as far as like things
like Best Lead Actor I've only seen one
of these performances and I haven't seen
the rest of them I haven't seen any of
the performances up for Best Actress I
have seen one of the performances for
Supporting Actor none of the ones for
Supporting Actress animated feature I
honestly I'm kind of glad frozen ii
didn't get a nomination i think what
they put in was more deserving i would
have liked
lego movie to to get a nomination but
they spurned the first one for
completely BS reasons so i knew what it
was it wasn't gonna get a look-in anyway
so i knew better than to hold out hope
for that one but then we get into the
technical cinematography etc etc etc um
if I were to make a animated ones the
one I've I feel like I've seen the most
in though I still haven't seen a decent
chunk of them I'm probably gonna end up
pulling for Toy Story 4 which was way
better than I had any right to be so let
me pop I'm back in the chat see what I'm
missing only scene Joker and little whim
and macey Joe Joe soon okay
just kicked off this year watching a few
films that got released back-to-back the
gentlemen Joe Joe Rabbit Little Women oh
you've been busy okay so frozen 2 was
badly written I'm gonna disagree I don't
think it was badly written in a vacuum
it does not hold a candle to the writing
of the first one because the writing of
the first one was so tight and the
second one is just it isn't it's very
it's very loose comparatively so it's a
step down
to its own predecessor certainly just
watch the first episode of Dracula
enjoying it so far I said I finished
that last night actually I had started
watching it before I make my usual Oscar
predictions on a radio show for the
third year in a row well best of luck to
you what last time I made Oscar
predictions I won my Oscar pool so I've
got a decent track record of doing that
and that is despite not having to see
most of the movies I actually think in
terms of predictions which I don't know
if I'm gonna make them here but in terms
of predictions actually not having seen
the movies might make me better at it
because I just look at the politics and
I don't mean politics like left-wing
right-wing I mean the internal industry
politics that tend to dominate how the
Oscars go and just going off that and
establish precedent I tend to do pretty
well so you know toss a coin to your
witch or a valley of Plenty okay can
only afford to see three films
back-to-back cuz of the mad stacks I'm
making on that thumbnail salary uh
you're you're you're uh you do wonderful
work Joel don't ever let anyone tell you
otherwise anyway so
oh jeez can you say what you mean by
tight and loose writing go watch my
review mainly I'm talking about the
theming all the themes were incredibly
tightly knit throughout nearly
everything that went on in the first
frozen the theming is not nearly as
carefully laid out across the entire
film in the second one it just isn't so
I got accepted to my colleges Honor
Society congratulations Connor so coming
back to the Oscars themselves let's
let's deal with the elephant in the room
let's talk about Joker
so let us um first establish I did not
especially like Joker I did not hate it
I didn't think it was a terrible movie I
thought it was a pretentious movie I
thought it was a movie that had a lot of
the trappings of trying to be about
something but it couldn't make a strong
a decision about what it wanted to be
about and I know people have tried to
make the argument to me like oh but it's
about all those things like but it's not
it acknowledges a ton of stuff I'm not
sure that it's about any of it and for
some people it worked and that's fine
it's one of those movies that people
want to paint everyone is either loving
or hating I feel neither way I did not
particularly enjoy it but I don't hate
it and I'm not mad at other people for
liking it I am mad at a lot of fans of
Joker being jerks about the way in which
they liked it but you know separate
issue but anyways it getting 11
nominations caught me very off guard I
think it caught a lot of people
off-guard
the thing is in many ways I think in
terms of the nominations it is a
beneficiary of the timing and the
politics and Harley if you are sorry
Harry Harry if you uh if you keep
spamming the chat we're gonna mute you
so yeah just don't that see that's not a
finger wave but that's exactly what I'm
talking about when I say I do hate the
way some fans of this film act about it
you basically just made my point by
spamming my chat and I don't know if you
were doing it as a joke
or if you were doing it sincerely but
from my point of view it doesn't matter
because what you were doing was spamming
my chat I don't really care if you meant
it as a joke or not anyways coming back
to the film I think Joker is a
beneficiary of the industry and box
office politics of the time which is the
Academy very much has and it knows it
knows it has a relevance problem but it
also doesn't know how to deal with it
because its head is stuck up its own but
collectively as an organization so it's
a well remark fact at this point that
most people don't see or haven't seen
most of the films that get nominated for
Oscars at this point that was a shift
that started happening in the 90s and
then pervaded going forward and in a lot
of ways it kind of culminated when 2008
came around or I guess since the movie
came out in 2008 the it was the 2009
Oscars came around and the Dark Knight
was omitted off a Best Picture and the
year after that was when they upped the
number of nominees for Best Picture to
up to 10 and it it was a very
transparent attempt by the Academy to be
to trying to appear relevant because
opening up more nominations was the only
way they were gonna get actually popular
movies on the on the billing at all and
that was why you know the following year
we saw nominations for things like
district 9 like avatar like up and I'm
not gonna say that was a bad thing but
it was a cynical move but the Academy
keeps has been trying to keep dealing
with that and understand any of the
films that I mentioned the ones I
mentioned or any of the ones that I'm
about to mention including Joker my
saying that it's nomination is cynical
does not mean it doesn't deserve the
nomination it just means that whether or
not it does deserve it is not the reason
it got it so with something like if we
look at last year and we look at Black
Panther that was and
I feel personally a deserved nomination
but again if you pay attention to the
politics going on in the industry at all
it was very clear that the Academy is
where all the snobs are and they don't
like how monstrously popular what in
their mind is junk cinema is right now
and Supriyo is at the heart of that so
when something like black panther comes
along which has a lot more on its mind
and a very different aesthetic in terms
of the design and the way that it's
going about things yet was also
monstrously popular that's on a silver
platter for the Oscars because they can
go oh this has social relevance and it's
popular oh look how plugged in we are
and Joker is basically that for this
year I actually will bet you that the
Academy was so happy when Joker came out
because before that for them to
acknowledge the superhero genre which
they don't like to do but they kind of
have to if they don't want to look like
they've got blinders on to what 90% of
the movie-going audience likes to see
right now their best option was Avengers
end game and I guarantee you they did
not want to nominate Avengers end game
so Joker comes out and suddenly they can
appear to be in and acknowledging and
bestowing prestige on this sub-genre
that has been dominating the industry
while doing it for a film that
deliberately snubs
most of the conventions and visual
stylings of that genre it is like I'm
not say it was designed as Oscar bait
but for the climate of the Oscars right
now it was the perfect bait for the
Oscars because it's plugged into the
stuff that they know is popular but
don't like acknowledging but it is
distanced enough from it that they don't
feel
like they're compromising themselves by
nominating it and there you go with
Joker I still did not expect 11
nominations that's still that threw me
off massively and some of them like in
this when the movie picked up best sound
ours best score at the Golden Globes I
was like wait what
and same with it getting nominated for
it here and it's not because I thought
the score wasn't good but it's cuz I
don't remember the score of that movie
at all the only music I remember were
the super obvious needle drop you know
time appropriate music tracks that were
played so that that boggles me but I'll
get into some of the specific
nominations that it that it picked up in
a little bit I want to kind of break
from talking Joker and come on back to
the chat and see what I've missed which
is probably a lot netflix having the
most Oscar nom sub all studio is
probably the biggest story um it is but
they're not they're not gonna win most
if any of those categories so much like
the superhero movie they were you know
the comic book movie getting a lot of
named shins and a lot of nominations I
don't think Joker's gonna win most of
these categories so you know it's it's
debatable how much that matters because
a nomination doesn't have to mean Oh an
award has meaning a nomination has a
little but not a ton doesn't tie them
down the way an actual award does you
didn't like Joker because insert we live
in society here Joker yeah yeah yeah
pretty much John Hurt was nominated for
the Oscars for the film Midnight Express
and Elephant Man Oh Rebecca you're back
with doctor who related Oscar trivia I
love it
I don't know Black Panther was good but
not Best Picture good in my opinion well
it's debatable what what a Best Picture
nominees supposed to me and the thing is
they call it Best Picture
none of this is actually meant to be the
best picture the it's a weird
amalgamation and it's kind of it muddies
the waters that they call it best
picture cuz that's not really what it is
and that's not really what it is ever
been thought Logan could have been
easier for the for them to swallow yeah
I would have thought Logan would have
picked up a few more um but you know so
I may say hold on what bugs me is that
most people are hung up on the superhero
bias but in a year we had us midsummer
doctors sleep in the lighthouse what
about the horror bite oh they've always
had a horror bias like what what what
horror movies have gotten major
nominations last one was Silence of the
Lambs that was a fluke like history is
borne out that that is an absolute fluke
I sell you see uncut gems i-i've heard
good things about that I don't usually
comment on movies I haven't seen but
Joker looks like taxi driver with Jokers
Travis Bickle it basically is and I'll
come back to that Peter Capaldi won an
Oscar for best short film you did you're
right anyways uh big man I'm not saying
Silence of the Lambs wasn't good I'm
saying that the fact that a horror movie
which it is you can call it a thriller
or whatever you want the fact that it's
a horror movie that had it won as many
Oscars as it did that is the fluke not
that the movie wasn't good it was but it
winning went in opposition of the
politics of the era so it's a fluke and
honestly Lord of the Rings was a fluke
they managed to stretch it out for three
Oscars in a row and then do the Queen
and clean sweep where the Return of the
King but that was a fluke that was a
fantasy fluke the way that sunset lamps
was a horror fluke so I'm not understand
when I say these things I'm a surprise
that got nomination I'm not talking
about the qualities of the films I'm
talking about the way that the Oscar
Paul
things tend to pan out best picture just
means most Oscar baiting and self-loving
not always um they they surprised me
sometimes like I was very pleasantly
surprised when shape of water one that
actually that meant a lot to me when
that one especially because I was
expecting three billboards to win and
that would have ticked me off badly so I
still don't like the bunch of the actors
one for that but you know it's not their
fault they didn't write it if it's a
blockbuster it won't get nominated not
for the big ones they'll pick up the
technical Awards us was my favorite of
the movie the year because I saw it on a
date because it was good us was
incredible but anyway I need to come
back to talking about how I saw the
first episode of Dracula so um I did
finish it I'm intrigued I want to see
where it's going it is it is the kind of
bunkers that I would expect from Moffat
and Gaydos because it's the kind of
reverie of the material yet going nuts
with it that they kind of did with
Sherlock I'm hoping it doesn't drive off
a cliff by the time it's done the way
Sherlock did but here's here's the thing
I think Damien sim from doctor who
should play the Joker in the sequel I
don't know what that is
now here here's the here's the thing
about the Dracula huh
I enjoyed it I did but and and I liked
the guy who played Dracula a lot more
than I thought I would
why didn't Marvin Marvin and gave us Jew
Jekyll No
moffat by himself on that one I'm gonna
tell you something that sounds like a
spoiler but it only happens like two
three minutes into the thing but when I
heard this I if I had been drinking
something I would have done a spit-take
as it was I simply shouted out loud
whoop tuff a word that I'm not gonna say
on the live stream so a gaunt emaciated
Jonathan Parker is being interviewed by
a nun about him escaping um
Castle Dracula and she asked him
straight-faced
did you have sexual intercourse with
Count Dracula and then the credits the
opening credits start after that it
takes a lot in what what's really funny
about that is that after that it goes
into like a crazy faithful for like
maybe a half hour or so a crazy faithful
adaptation and it doesn't get that crazy
again that nuts again until the tail end
of the first episode and I haven't seen
past the first episode so no spoilers in
here but yeah it does it does sort of
come back to that level of crazy and
sort of I'm sorry what but it's it's
crazy in an enjoyable way and if you're
if you're going to go nuts I think I
think it makes a lot of sense to go nuts
on a fairly established very well worn
oft-repeated story because everyone
knows the way this story normally goes
so let's go crazy with it for a little
bit
rise up Skywalker getting manam for Best
Original Score is a big joke um it is a
little bit odd given that how much of it
is based off you know
musical motifs from the previous films
either the immediate two proceedings or
the ones before that but I mean you know
it's John Williams he's grandfathered in
to get nominations forever
there was only three episodes a month of
Dracula can't even often mess things up
in that amount of time you're yeah yeah
I can remembers face the Raven Heaven
Sent hell-bent yeah give him give him
three episodes he can do it I'm hoping
Gaydos keeps him in check see here's the
funny thing I actually like Gaydos as a
writer when he isn't writing Doctor Who
so and I feel like he restrains Moffat
at least a little bit a fair amount of
the time when they work together
the BBC Jekyll show that did kind of
fall apart by the end but like I said
that was Moffat on his own oh I love the
fact that gay this is a gay man I yeah I
mean good for him I suppose I don't know
I'm just I'm just not entirely sure why
he came up but yeah no fun what are your
favorite and least favorite Best Picture
winners Oh
cuz he the thing is there's a lot of
Best Picture winners that I refuse to
see I have never seen crash I'm never
gonna see crash I kind of refuse to see
that um I didn't see green book I don't
want to see it so it's hard for me to
say if I were to pick a favorite at
least from the last 20 years it would be
shape of water so like that that movie
meant a lot to me on a personal level
well things get as heated as they did
when green book one I follow numerous
people with very different opinions on
that film same as Joker then the thing
is I'm not gonna say that green books a
bad film I'm not sure that it is I
haven't seen it but it was a very it
would
from its structure and what it was doing
it's the kind of movie that like you
would engineer in a lab to win Oscars so
it winning felt very disappointing
sometimes it feels like there are
critics that are incapable of
objectively absorbing a film for what it
is or what isn't well look here's the
thing Connor there is no such thing as
objective criticism the quickest way to
get me to disregard any comment anybody
leaves is when they accuse me in a
review of not being objective no critic
is objective an objective review of
Joker would go like this Joker was a
film released by Warner Brothers
it runs for a hundred and twenty minutes
it stars Joaquin Phoenix as a character
who eventually identifies as the Joker
it also stars these other people at the
end of the movie there were credits
that's an objective review if you're
judging the quality it's a subjective
judgement because it's filtered through
you subjectively as a person so like
whenever I see the word objective
anywhere near the word critic or
critical or criticism I'm just I check
out mentally that said it some critics
are very bad at acknowledging what their
subjective viewpoint is and that is its
own problem because it critics buy into
the idea that they are objective that's
like Oh God's sake that that results in
some really bad criticism but even
beyond that it and it's fine for a
credit to be subjective but I think it's
important that they give the audience
some sort of view of how they are
subjectively viewing something which is
well I it's very common for me whenever
I talk about anything to say look I just
don't get it or this is my history with
this kind of
or this kind of thing just appeals to me
because maybe I can't justify it but I
can just give you a little bit of
insight into me to understand enough why
I like it
then you it'll be your own call as to
whether or not that's a reason you would
like it or not oh and before I say it
cuz I keep forgetting to say it I'm so
annoyed knives out I did not get more
nominations and and the I forget her
name now but the woman who who played
the nurse she deserved a nomination so
much she was so good ah I'm just
depressed that doctor who's no longer an
Amazon Prime yeah that is annoying
you're approaching objectivity
subjectively yeah well I'm a human being
I do
everything's objectively did you see dr.
sleep I did not I heard very good things
did you did you see conjure points as
video and canceled culture of course I
did I had to watch it in chunks it's a
lot to get through
especially if any of what you read rings
a bell it's a lot but it was very well
put together I like her work in general
I pretty much always AB for as long as
I've been watching her stuff gotta love
the water oh yeah it's important to
hydrate have you seen the lighthouse I
have not
have you seen Good Omens yeah I've got a
review up gate is his best Doctor Who
story was the novel and later Big Finish
adaptation nightshade
I might have to add that to my Big
Finish list my to-do list contra points
this video was super good and
depresses me as she went through such
things the Internet can be a really
toxic place don't blame the internet
people can't be toxic all the internet
is is a means by which people can do
things that people are inclined to do
Internet's a tool like anything else and
much like a hammer you can use it to
build a house or you can use it to break
somebody's fingers I want to see knives
out can't help but wonder if part of it
is out of spite against price of the
Skywalker
oh look as someone who didn't like
return to the Jedi knives out is great
its Rian Johnson to me exactly what he's
good at
and it works here for me in a way that
didn't in the last Jedi so there are
three British YouTube channels you
should check out Seneca reviews cynic
snacks boxes productions they're all
Boreum haven't heard of any of them
I'm noticing a repetition of the word
cynical have you folks figured me out
that well here's the thing I I am
cynical but my aim is to not be a bummer
to be around because of it I do my best
to be the most pleasant cynic that I can
be are you gonna watch Sonic the
Hedgehog when it comes out I don't I'll
probably see it eventually but I don't
know if I'm planning to brush it is it
that's one of those movies that's that's
gonna fall under the do I have anything
else to do and if the answer's no then
maybe we'll say like I'm glad I am glad
Klaus got nominated my opinion best
animated film 2019 I still haven't seen
it visually it's great have you ever
heard of the book picture Oh ham
pictures out of revolution by Mark
Harris it's about the 1967 Best Picture
nominees and the journeys from
production Oscar night no didn't know
that one so I suppose jumping back to
the Oscars real quick you know
let's just roll on through and let's go
category by category for a little bit uh
I gotta be honest Best Picture is very
tough to call because I don't think
there is an easy thing for them to go
with the the Academy members
historically have not really liked
Tarantino all that much so I kind of be
surprised if once upon a time in
Hollywood got it Ford V Ferrari has a
shot but that's more or less by default
the Irishman don't get it won't get it
cuz it came out on Netflix and there's
too much politics involved in that
marriage story honestly I think it's too
low-key them to go for nineteen
seventeen has a shot I think um that
falls under the possibility I think
parasite might have the best shot at it
if if the Oscar voters actually bother
to see it that's that's actually the
legitimate problem is getting all the
Oscar voters to actually see these dang
things and that's part of why subtitles
films even when they're nominated for
Best Picture frequently don't do well
Jojo rabbit I think is to deliberately
politically charged they won't touch it
and little women it's like I don't know
like the third adaptation of it I'd be
surprised if they went with that actor
on a lead role I do think they I do
think Joaquin Phoenix will get that the
only reservation I'd put on that at all
is there might be some hesitation to now
give an Oscar on two occasions to actors
who have played a variant of the same
character there might be some hesitation
around that but for my money Joaquin
Phoenix he still gets that um actress
and a leading role
I don't know I mean I'm fortunately like
first off I haven't seen any of these so
again this judgement has nothing to do
with with what's the best at a guess
it's not gonna be social Ronin because
she's young she'll get nominated again
Charlize maybe I don't know if bombshell
is a little bit too loaded but then
again it's loaded in a direction that
they're that they're usually comfortable
with so maybe Scarlett for a marriage
story possible Renee Zellweger for Judy
I don't think so
Cynthia areevo for Harriet I don't know
I think if I were to guess I'd say it's
probably either gonna be Charlize Theron
or Cynthia areevo between the two I
don't know that's that's a tough call
supporting actor this is the one that
they might sneak in and the Irish man
might snag something
Al Pacino might pick this one up cuz he
basically came out of retirement to do
it so this is kind of their last chance
to award him with anything Tom Hanks I
don't think he'll get it
I wasn't surprised that he was out of it
but I don't think he'll get it Brad Pitt
on an outside shot maybe no to Anthony
Hopkins no Al Pacino so for my money Joe
Pesci maybe Brad Pitt actress in a
supporting role let's see Kathy Bates
Florenz peu Margot Robbie Robbie's not
gonna get it Johansson's not gonna get
it um they'll probably give it to Laura
Dern yeah uh animated feature film this
is a tough one because normally Pixar is
your safe bet but like there's a four on
the end of that and the Academy doesn't
love awarding sequels especially ones
that don't feel like I continuing part
of the same story like Lord of the Rings
Willis
they they might throw a bone to Lika and
give it to missing link on that Klaus
won't get it again because Netflix I
lost my body that's the token arthouse
one not enough of them will actually
watch it that won't win I would say it's
either gonna be missing link or Toy
Story 4 I think like I might actually
pick it up this time
cinematography 1917 the whole gimmick of
shooting the whole thing in one shot and
to do it with this huge action heavy
thing yeah 1917 gets that that's that's
a lock costume design little women
that'll take that Academy loves period
costumes directing okay this one alright
this is the one Joker nomination that
I'm annoyed at as opposed to just
slightly surprised by and that is
because regardless of how good you think
the movie is the entire mo going into it
which was this is not some position
this was the declared intention of the
film was to look like a Scorsese film
Scorsese produced it and Todd Phillips
aped a lot of Scorsese stuff
specifically taxi driver while directing
it and I'm not even saying he did it
badly nor am i saying that that is
somehow an invalid way to direct a film
of course you can aim somebody else's
style if you think that style fits the
story you're gonna tell go for it
however I do take issue with awarding
someone whose entire approach was to
make it look like somebody else
it I don't know that that feels like
that feels like giving a Grammy Award to
a cover yeah and maybe they do that I
don't know I don't follow the Grammys
but that it's that kind of it's that
kind of thing it's like but but it's not
really your you you made it like
something and especially given all the
other directors who weren't nominated in
that category who I thought would have
made more sense than Todd Phillips and I
say that not getting into anything about
any of the stuff the guy said I don't
want to touch any of that just in terms
of what the film Joker is that
nomination annoys me if I were to guess
I'd say that bong joon-ho probably has
the best shot I still don't know if
parasite will win the big prize but for
my money he picks up directing
documentary I haven't seen any of these
so there's no thing when I do the Oscar
pool there's a handful of categories
that are basically just blind guesses
and you can maybe look up a couple of
things about like what the subject is
and try and figure out which is more
likely to tug at the heartstrings of the
of the Academy voters but documentary
both feature and short those are gonna
be blind two guesses for me so I'm not
even gonna dwell on that editing hmm
that is a tough call between those
nominees at I guess I'm gonna say either
parasite maybe Jojo rabbit international
film if parasite doesn't win Best
Picture
it will win international film that
might be its consolation prize makeup
makeup might go to Joker maybe might
also go to bombshell because they like
they like it when actresses are made up
to look like like other people so which
would qualify Judy as well but there's
more of them in bombshell
so I think bombshells probably got the
best shot at makeup music uh I don't
know
it won't be Star Wars I mean I suppose
it might be Joker given that that picked
up the Golden Globe but again that still
boggles me yeah I don't know about music
original song um well I can say that I
hope it goes to Elton John for I'm gonna
love me again but that's a hard call if
it's not that it might end up being into
the unknown because that's probably the
one that most of the voters have had
kids play in the car Oh working over and
over again production design that
production design might go to once upon
a time in Hollywood if not that then
probably Jojo rabbit short film animated
I don't know only one of these i saw was
hair love which was great that was a
great short that was terrific short film
live-action and haven't seen any of them
sound editing um 19:17 will take that
sound mixing nineteen seventeen will
take that too
those two are almost always paired
together visual effects um they might
toss avengers end game a bone for that
one screenplay adapted I'm gonna say
goes to George Oh rabbit and original
screenplay
that'll be knives out which it deserves
but it deserves a lot more than that but
there you go
so let me pop on back here doing
ah all right
so I'm sure I've missed a lot in the
chat apologies there remember many of
the Beatles big pre experimental hits
were covers of us soul songs yeah but
again I'm not saying that it doesn't
make them good I'm saying if you're
going to recognize something as a piece
of art it is odd to do it for what is
effectively a directorial cover you know
or maybe you don't know maybe I'm not
making any sense
maybe I am talking complete and utter
nonsense and no one should listen to me
you make the call and pop into the
discord real quick see what's going on
over there um and we are gonna have to
wrap this one up on time cuz I got a lot
of stuff to do tonight but let me see
I guess not too many questions in the
discord I think probably because it
wasn't a topic that lent itself to hey
what are your thoughts on blitek cuz the
entire premise of this live stream was
here are my thoughts on big that's what
I'm gonna start calling them the the the
20/20 annual boo Awards the Academy of
Motion Picture and Blair ten the next
page round perk be choosing Nathaniel
ser color no like if I put it up as a
joke that a certain tier of the patient
would be you get to pick my next hair
color it would be very high it would be
intentionally prohibitively high then we
might like someone would do it anyway
I bet there are more Broadway actors
named Tony that have won a Tony then
there are movie actors named Oscar ov
one of an Oscar that's somebody's look
on that somebody look into that I don't
know because it depends on whether or
not you're allowed to you just shortened
the name even if the actor doesn't so
like if I actor's name is Anthony are we
allowed to say that Tony won a Tony but
or do they have to be called Tony like
in their official credits you gotta set
rules out for these things folks you
define your terms set your parameters um
that's about all that was here alright
cool so coming on back people have
bitten four whole series so that's a
sucker's but okay alright Caroline
that's a fair point I I did set the like
the review of whole series worth of
stuff at a very high price point and
somebody did do it but like my point is
if I were to auction off my hair color
it would be higher than that was which
is like I can't imagine that anybody
would care enough even if the intention
was to mess with me to spend that kind
of money to do it oh you made it John
nice to see ya
I think the orphan 55 speech wasn't
there cuz the writer thought we wouldn't
get the message because they wanted to
scare people taking the issue seriously
but the episode wasn't scary I mean end
of the day doesn't matter whether was
hammering home a message because they
thought we didn't get it
or trying to put a button on a scare
thing as you said it wasn't scary so
whichever one it was it still failed
it's just a question of which thing it
was trying to accomplish have you ever
worn or one of those huge dresses they
happen little women I swear it would
cause a person to lose several pounds no
I've never I have never been in one of
those big flouncy puffy multilayered
three petticoats sorts of things no I've
never worn one of those one person named
Oscar has won an Oscar three Tony's have
won a Tony thank you tiffy that was that
was a prompt response I'm quite
impressed how quickly you got that out
oh god orphan 55 was mentioned run
everybody to your security bunkers
whatever Luke it was it was an on brain
episode of Doctor Who it's over there's
a new one on Sunday I didn't like it
either
so what get over yourselves every
nomination this year was a period film
his parasite a period film tomorrow's
the anniversary of my uncle's funeral
I'll be watching colony in space it was
the FIR it was first given to me by him
for Christmas it was the first classic
whose story ever saw oh that's really
sweet Ben I'm sorry that you lost him
but that's I think that's a really sweet
way to remember him
I've been ranting Harding your doctor
who review comments I'm sorry like you
and about 50 other people so you know
I'm not exactly gonna hold it against
you
did you know all the actress to play the
master who are still alive are starring
in a Big Finish next year to celebrate
the anniversary of the master yeah I did
I didn't know that that's also on my you
know list of things that I hope to get
to but you know time it never stops
moving so who knows when we'll get to
that we got about ten minutes left so
let's see the Tonys are actually named
the Antoinette Awards and nobody named
Antoinette has ever won one ah
interesting
well I mean Oscar is also a nickname so
you know that's valid I almost feel like
the speech at the end of wharfing could
have been tacked on by script editor I
mean it just it was just jarring it just
it did not flow into it smoothly at all
and Doctor Who can have very on-the-nose
speeches but it has to flow through the
story and through the characters in the
situation that they're in that scale
model of war speech in Saigon inversion
is not subtle it is blunt it is lay out
exactly the themes in the message of the
episodes but it's also believably what
the doctor would be saying to these
people under these circumstances and the
situation brings it about organically
it's the lack of that that makes the
orphan 55 speech fail it's less the
speech itself and more they did not
build proper context around it to have
it work currently borrowing my dad's
classic Doctor Who DVD so the entire
collection is on my shelf he has four or
five four or five and I have 25 I
nice ah YouTube's been spamming me with
auntie who recommendations it makes me
crazy oh man
see the thing is I actually haven't been
watching a lot of other hoot I mean like
the ones who I subscribe to normally
I've been watching so that's like a
scree / crispy pro you know the those
folks and a few others I like I have
been watching but I I don't I don't pay
attention to Doctor Who recommendations
my recommendations have been directing
me to a lot of music based stuff because
I decided to binge through Todd in the
shadows one-hit wonder land again so
I've got a lot of music related videos
and my recommendations right now I'm
really enjoying the new master he's kind
of like if classic series master at a
really really short temper I like him so
far i I want to see his next appearance
because I would both the doctor on the
master I always need at least two
appearances to really get be certain
that they are what I think they are
because you know otherwise they might
act differently under different
circumstances so there's that but so far
I'm down with it because my
eight-year-old watches a lot of
minecraft tutorials on my account that's
what I get a lot of recommendations for
Lee I imagine that gets old I would have
preferred a long fleshed out monologue
like the speech I wanna flesh out my
monologue then the speech we got an
orphan 55 they could have ditched the
father-son plot all together to have
time for it I don't think the issue was
time though I think the issue was just
finding the right circumstances to have
it happen I think honestly I think it
also would be helped if it wasn't the
last thing in the episode I think if the
doctor had gotten just really frustrated
at the like in the moment before they've
escaped I think it might have worked if
the
dr. got really frustrated with the
denial of Graham Ryan and yaz being like
no this can't be this can't be earth and
she kind of has a moment of wake up yes
it can
you had the warnings you didn't do
anything about it you bet your ass this
is earth and then like from that you
know she has her moment to vent at them
and it can be mean even but then we get
back into the story again because they
still haven't escaped yet it can be a
bit like say when the doctor got really
upset in the Beast below and he was like
nobody human has any right to speak to
me today it could be something like that
and you could have gotten the message
and even that degree of frustration in
there and I think it would have landed
better if it wasn't the last thing in
the episode I think that that did it a
disservice making it literally the last
thing because like I said I immediately
thought of old masters of the universe
or you know for other people maybe GI
Joe I didn't really watch that one but
you know the lesson at the end well boys
and girls here's the lesson and you got
to remember to turn off the lights in
your house you know that sticking at the
end reinforced that feeling so I think
that was part of the problem too to be
completely honest they've been
complaining about the upgrade comment
and spy fall ignoring that it's not
really out of character for the doctor
to view his buddy's an upgrade it's not
what I thought it was out of character
and complain about it I just felt like
between that and some of the stuff in
spy fall part 2 I did think that they
were it did feel like poking the bear
either one in isolation fine but like
two episodes in a row as part of the
same story I was a bit like are we just
being are we just needling at this point
your daughter likes Amaral yeah aminals
yeah your daughter likes animals they
show like a blue head
dog I don't know I don't know if she has
any clue who Sonic the Hedgehog is uh
I'm not gonna tell her if she tells me
she wants to see the movie I'll take her
to it I'm not bringing it to her
attention I'm really nervous about the
timeless child thing Oh God
on the plus side it could mean we see
Rassilon and omega back i want rice on
to be recast as charles dance what is it
with all you people Charles dance
Charles dance for the master Charles is
for razz lot first of all Rassilon needs
to be done barring the casting of
somebody like Charles dance I think he
just needs to be done
um but yeah I'm not I'm not looking
forward to the finding out about the
timeless child either just cuz I don't I
don't want I don't want I don't want
that arc I don't want the mystery box
arc anymore I just don't um well you
send your spy phone review but the
timeless child arc made me think I feel
like it won't be answered this season we
got set up series 11 reminder series 12
answer in series 13 okay but even if
that's the case that won't change my
opinion of it because that's just a
mystery box Trek stretched over three
series instead of over the course of one
it's the same dang thing and again huh
people seem to keep forgetting I am NOT
saying that every single one of the
mystery box plots before didn't work or
were somehow bad some of them were great
I'm just sick of the format there are
other ways to do this
oh do you think the Carmel master plans
reveal could work if no no I'm not even
gonna read the rest of that question no
the answer's no no will you sell your
soul for creative success um I would
need to get a proper appraisal of my
soul first because I don't know what
kind of condition it's in and honestly
if it's beat up enough maybe it's worth
it for me to just unload it at a premium
price but like I gotta get an appraiser
in here first before I even think about
answering that question Charles dance
for mail Ronnie Oh God
would you mind Bela coming back
with Ryan worked for me um from a
chemistry angle no from a plot angle I
think I would like I'm not sure if
there's anywhere to go with that have
you heard of nerd tronic yes I have okay
you know what
ha ha let's get something on the record
here right now because it pops up in the
and this is actually the note I'm gonna
end up ending this stream on so it pops
up intermittently either in comments or
people hit me up on Twitter or what have
you the idea that I should debate people
like nerd tronic or bolus Trek or
clownfish TV or folks like that who are
on the very far end a very far away from
me on the whole this is all progressive
agenda and it's ruined this thing type
of things
I will never debate these people ever
and let me be clear it is not because I
think they're bad people it's not
because I even think that there's no
value in what is they have to say the
reason I won't do it ever is because
there is no benefit for anybody for me
to do that what I would do in the case
of any or all of the people I just
mentioned I would sit down
privately over a cup of coffee and just
talk like to human beings no recorders
no audience those are the circumstances
under which I would talk to those sorts
of people and those sorts of youtubers
because I would like to honestly pick
their brains a little bit about what it
is that they say what it is they see
that I don't agree with but I won't do
it publicly I will not do it in a debate
setting because there is nothing to be
gained from that the incense there's an
the instant there's an audience the
instant that there is any means to
record the conversation then it
immediately becomes performative it
become because if I go in on this side
of a debate up against to talk to
somebody on this side of the debate and
our positions are pre established before
we even come in neither of us has any
reason to concede any ground because any
ground given will be viewed as weakness
and will be viewed as the other side
winning and no but you're in those
situations those debates you're not
trying to convince anybody of anything
you're just trying to put on a good show
for whoever the people who already agree
with you are there is zero benefit to
actually listening to actually having a
conversation I would happily have a
conversation privately with any of these
people I will never ever do a youtube or
publicly viewed or recorded debate with
them ever so that's that's where I am on
that and I wanted to put it on the
record because I'm not gonna say it gets
asked a ton but it gets asked
sporadically enough and with enough
regularity that it like let's get let's
get this official on the record ah there
are times I dread looking for Doctor Who
channels on YouTube because I don't want
to come across the channel that is
nothing but piles of hate fest Rebecca I
would highly recommend you take a look
at at this past year's top fifty you top
fifty who tubers that SL productions put
out those are nominated by the who do
fan community none of those are hate
Watchers so far as I know and that's 50
channels that you can check out some
very small some about I guess about as
big as me there were one or two more
then I have that are on that list but
that's that's a list that you can trust
people aren't he watching the show so go
for that
[Music]
Susan should turn out to be the other
nothing the other needs to not exist
just don't just don't and if you don't
know what I'm talking about don't look
it up it's stupid it was a stupid idea
we would we dodged a bullet that had
never got done and so help me if if that
is the PlayBook Chibnall is playing from
if he dug up the corpse of the Cartmell
master plan and that's his big endgame
I'm gonna be really annoyed cuz it was
dumb idea then it's a dumb idea now okay
find some calm after stream don't
waterboard yourself over it I can handle
myself just fine hmm that's usually
assigned to stop but then again Jodi and
Kris will eventually leave and then what
will those eight channels do after that
well most of them are also you know
pulling at Star Wars and CW shows and
Star Trek discovered like they find
stuff but finally got a stream while
live oh good to see RC I'm wrapping up I
always feel bad when when people like
pop on it's like oh I made this tree but
I'm like I'm ending it in a minute the
sex cloud from day one is the other sure
why not
there we go
alright everybody thanks for tuning in
ah so do you smoke pot no I don't I have
not I god I think the last time I smoked
pot was probably five years ago
roundabout yeah no it's not it's never
really been my thing at any point which
is strange if chip no uses his since
from what I understand he dislikes McCoy
doctor I don't know about them
oh excuse me I don't know about that but
thanks for the stream take care have fun
thank you everybody else is well I hope
I hope everybody has a good rest of the
week I'm this this this week is not not
exactly been a joy at work oh well have
a great night you know Thank You Donna
very much um but thank you all for
tuning in listening to me ramble basking
in the glory that is my hair haha so
thanks for everybody thanks everybody
for tuning in and just remember that you
are beautiful you are loved you are
valid you are the council I'm just
finding the meetings have a good night